and I can say that in my 83 years
I feel more spry than ever and that's
because I discovered the Fountain of
Youth has it were and what's that the
young turks god bless him they're
holding out hope and they just had a
video that they recently released with
some incredible well okay first off what
point were they addressing let's watch i
was recently in washington and a lot of
people understandably asked me hey you
know what do you think Genk who's gonna
run on the Democratic side in 2020 for
president and this is where a little
about the young turks the video started
and I've already learned something yeah
yeah it's pronounced Jeng Jeng they're
always looking out for the other guy
so what's the point of this video who
does jank thank you think should run
against Trump in 2020 what fresh idea
does he have for their so called the
resistance when you get past Bernie
Sanders it's not entirely clear who
would that's right Bernie Sanders
because nothing says fresh like a 95
year old and I love that you know the
Young Turks and all the people in their
network the secular talk they they're
this they're really holding how I know
many we're thinking Bernie Sanders is
going to be too old thank God djenka
dresses that well Bernie Sanders is
gonna be too old well what's the mess
let's investigate that okay twenty when
the election is Bernie Sanders will be
79 right but Donald Trump would be 75
hillary clinton or god forbid will be 73
a person who's often mentioned in these
conversations elizabeth warren obese 71
they're all in their 70s I propose that
maybe the most popular politician in the
country is the one
we should consider the front-runner okay
first off I don't think he understands
the definition of investigate okay let's
investigate that and here's what's
important just because you like
something or you really want something
doesn't make it so
now there's something called actuary
tables these tables calculate the
likelihood of death what shink fails to
tell now I don't know if it's just if
he's blinded by his is his loyalty is
support for Bernie Sanders or if he's
deliberately misleading his audience
look beat I mean it's if I can't be
clear sense of what it really is that's
the important thing here this is
something that they don't address listen
the chances of dying go up exponentially
past a certain age as a matter of fact
the likelihood of bernie sanders dying
in his first term as president would be
almost twice the chances of donald trump
dying in his second term as president
significance call it statistically
significant 25% for Bernie Sanders in
his first term versus 15% for Donald
Trump in his second term
why Bernie would be going in at 79 okay
that's a 3.8 Chant percent chance to
look at the actuary tables and he dies
at 79 cent zero three okay but then if
you look at when he is 83 which is when
he would be leaving it's over a six
percent chance where as Donald Trump in
his second term going into his second
term he'd only be at that three percent
chance now you have a few years we'll go
6% 5% 6% 8% 9% so each year you have it
three times sometimes sometimes three
times more likely to dying at let's say
85 then you do from 66 to 67 math sucks
math absolutely sucks it's very
difficult as possible and we don't want
to be here to pass judgment so um like
if Donald like Donald Trump if Bernie
Sanders were elected we want to give him
a fair chance and since we've had enough
people here joining the Mudd Club for
the daily program we've had an increase
in budget blessed we've been blessed and
we're trying to use it responsibly see
our TV mug Club members actually used it
to purchase a time machine yeah yeah
well use it to purchase time machine and
with that time machine we've opted today
to bring you an interview from 2020 with
future president Bernie Sanders future
president yeah future president Bernie
Sanders thank you for being with us sir
hey venture president Sanders thank you
for taking the time is my most precious
commodity well first off I'm sorry about
your wife doing multiple life sentences
for all our accounts of bank fraud right
off the bat do you feel as though I'm
where's my iPad I'm giving that one to
my press secretary Shaun King you'll get
an expense from me let's continue how
has America changed now under the future
president Bernie Sanders how is it
different from today compassionate place
no it's getting brighten here and those
1% who lived too high on the hog
Oh future president Bernie Sanders
everyone if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button it's a
circular button now that says subscribe
if not head on over the Young Turks
that's probably more your speed although
they're coming over at [ __ ] we know
you're here watching I can smell you
from here there's also a recommended
video box playing right up there you can
join the Hmong Club it allotted with
credit.com slash mug Club for daily
content so we're not dependent here on
YouTube shank no go you don't need to
stay here this isn't good for it's bad
for your soul